Olá pessoal aqui o Dr Alan Machado Dutra
para mais um vídeo sej muito bem-vindos
ao canal a bosua serrata também
conhecida como o Líbano é uma planta
originária das regiões áridas da Índia
norte da África e oriente médio esse
arbusto produz uma resina rica em
compostos bioativos amplamente utilizada
na medicina faz séculos entre os seus
principais benefícios são a capacidade
de reduzir inflamações aliviar dores
articulares e melhorar a função
respiratória além disso a bosua tem
mostrado promessas em estudos recentes
pro tratamento de doenças crônicas como
artrite e asma vamos falar então um
pouco sobre o impacto da bosua no
sistema de defesa imune a boswelia
possui uma capacidade notável de modular
o sistema imune O que explica o seu
papel efetivo na preservação da saúde e
no combate às doenças os estratos dessa
planta atuam como antiinflamatórios in
libindo citocinas e mediadores que são
conhecidos por danificar o DNA
contribuindo para o crescimento de
tumores e destruindo células saudáveis
então estudos recentes TM mostrado que
os óleos de olíbano e os extratos de
bosua podem estimular o sistema de
defesa imune e promover a saúde geral e
também outra propriedade é redução da
inflamação através de compostos ativos
azuela interfere na produção de várias
citocinas que promovem inflamação como é
o caso de ter feron Gama oficina 4 e
fator de necrose tumoral Alfa esse
mecanismo de ação ajuda a diminuir a
inflamação no corpo e é particularmente
benéfico para condições como artrite e
asma além disso a planta ajuda a
retardar reações à sensibilidades e
ajuda a regular interações importantes
entre linfócitos e células T
fundamentais para uma Resposta imune
saudável também vai promover o
fortalecimento da Defesa corporal os
estratos de bosua desempenham um papel
crucial na regula da produção de dois
tipos de anticorpos o IgG imunoglobulina
g e IGM imunoglobulina m o IgG é
essencial para combater infecções
bacterianas e virais enquanto o IGM é
encontrado principalmente no sangue no
fluido linfático sendo os principais
anticorpos a responder infecções essa
regulação fortalece o sistema imune e
aumenta a capacidade do corpo de se
defender contra vários agentes invasores
vamos falar então agora da composição
química da planta a resina da ela contém
cerca de 5% a 10% de óleos essenciais
puros ricos em compostos protetores como
monoterpenos diterpenos triterpenos e
asdos triterpênicas
propriedades anti-inflamatórias da
planta tornando ela uma poderosa aliada
na prevenção de doenças autoimunes e na
gestão da inflamação Vamos falar agora
dos principais benefícios alívio de
dores articulares e artrite estudos
indicam que a bosu Élia serrata pode
significativamente reduzir dores
especialmente em casos de osteoartrite e
outras condições articulares um estudo
revelou que pacientes com dor no joelho
experimentaram melhorias na dor maior
flexibilidade aumenta a capacidade de
caminhar após o tratamento com busua
essa eficácia é atribuída à suas ações
antiinflamatórias e analgésicas fazendo
da bzu um componente frequente em
suplementos dietéticos para a saúde das
articulações o segundo ponto redução da
inflamação ela contém substâncias
chamadas terpenos e ácidos bzu
Élica natural protegendo de danos nos
tecidos promovendo a saúde geral então o
seu extrato é tão poderoso que hoje é
considerado comparável aos analgésicos
antiinflamatórios não esteroidais o
principal tipo de medicamento
antiinflamatório que se usa Hoje em dia
a bzu atua diminuindo processos
inflamatórios no corpo o que é
particularmente benéfico sem os efeitos
colaterais comuns de medicamentos mais
fortes além de seus amplos benefícios
antiinflamatórios a bosua também é útil
no tratamento de problemas relacionados
à inflamação da próstata especialmente
em casos de hiperplasia prostática
benigna que no caso é a próstata grande
e é uma condição comum em homens mais
velhos no caso o aumento da próstata
pode causar problemas urinários como
dificuldade para começar a urinar um
fluxo fraco ou a necessidade de urinar
de forma frequente especialmente à noite
utilizar então bzu Élia pode ajudar a
reduzir a inflamação associado a hpb que
é a sigla da próstata grande melhorando
os sintomas e contribuindo para uma
melhor qualidade de vida além disso a
bosua vai promover aceleração da cura de
infecções ela é eficaz no tratamento de
várias infecções do trato respiratório e
também dos seios paranasais diminuindo a
gravidade e auxiliando na prevenção de
alergia e asma tradicionalmente é
utilizada na medicina chinesa para
melhorar a circulação sanguínea acelerar
a cura e tem propriedades Então já
falado várias vezes antiinflamatórias
que facilitam a respiração mostram o
potencial como antiviral ajudando no
tratamento dos vírus e outros agentes
patogênicos também a boswelia vai atuar
na prevenção de doenças autoimunes ela
tem sido iado historicamente para tratar
várias doenças autoimunes incluindo
artrite doenças inflamatórias
intestinais devido a sua capacidade de
modular a produção de componentes
inflamatórios pesquisas indicam que a
bosu Élia pode ajudar a induzir a
remissão em doenças como colit cativa
doença de cron são tipos de inflamações
intestinais crônicas melhorando
significativamente os sintomas e a
qualidade de vida dos pacientes e a
bosua também tem potencial contra o
câncer ela consegue combater vários
cânceres estudos sugerem que pode
proteger incluindo contra o Câncer de
cérebro mama próstata e estômago os
extratos de bosua e o óleo de olíbano
podem influenciar genes que promovem a
cura e reduzem os efeitos colaterais
severos dos tratamentos convencionais de
câncer como é o caso da quimioterapia e
da radioterapia Além disso ela tem
mostrado eficácia em reduzir dores
articulares e complicações digestórias
relacionadas ao tratamento do Câncer
Então vamos falar dos Suplementos à base
bzu ela pode ser consumida de duas
formas principais como suplemento ou
como óleo essencial de olíbano as duas
formas são válidas e são bem
interessantes se você optar por tomar
azuela como suplemento em cápsula é
importante escolher extratos
padronizados para que tenha um mínimo de
princípio ativo para garantir que você
está obtendo uma quantidade eficaz dos
ácidos buzu
Élica concentração de 65% ou mais desses
ácidos bosu
Élica pureza eficácia então ao iniciar o
uso de suplementos de bosua comece com
uma dose menor e aumente conforme
necessário seguindo sempre as instruções
da embalagem e você pode também combinar
a bzu com a curcumina ela é ainda mais
eficaz nessa combinação com a curcumina
que é o principal componente da cúrcuma
Então essa combinação potencializa os
efeitos antiinflamatórios de ambos
proporcionando um benefício adicional
pesquisadores sugerem que usar esses
dois agentes em conjuntos esses
fitoterápicos podem oferecer maior
proteção contra inflamações do que usar
apenas um agente de forma isolada e os
efeitos colaterais é só alegria não tem
efeitos colaterais sim embora a bosua
seja considerada bem tolerada de forma
geral alguns usuários podem experimentar
desconforto abdominal leve ou diarreia
se esses efeitos colaterais acontecerem
com você É aconselhável reduzir a dose é
importante não substituir qualquer
medicamento prescrito por suplemento de
bosua sem o conhecimento e anuência do
seu médico bosu e o Líbano são
geralmente seguros para crianças mas se
você estiver grávida é essencial não
iniciar o uso de bosua sem consultar
antes um médico ou profissional de saúde
da mesma forma se você estiver tomando
antiinflamatórios não esteroidais ou
outro tipo de medicamento consulte o seu
médico antes de começar a usar a bosua e
adicioná-la à sua rotina e o tempo de
ação tem em mente que os benefícios da
bosua podem demorar um pouco para se
manifestar é importante dar tempo ao
suplemento para que ele possa agir
eficazmente no corpo antes de decidir se
é ou não adequado para você muitos
fisioterápicos naturais como é o caso da
busua necessitam de algum tempo para
começar a mostrar os seus efeitos
benéficos Então tenha paciência espere
pelo menos 30 dias não desista
prematuramente do tratamento compartil
os
vos a de alguém pode também no can
muito obrigado por ter assiso esse vídeo
Um grande abraço um beijo seu coração